after dozens of hours in the
rough-and-tumble Commonwealth the coast
of Maine sounds like the perfect place
for a sojourn in fallout 4
enjoy a boat ride meet new people solve
a mystery with your best synthetic
friend what's not to love Who am I
kidding
fart Harbor is just as overrun with
radiation desperate factions and mutated
creatures as fallout 4s main stage along
its rocky shores and in its foggy woods
Llyod characters and rewarding side
quests along with the bounty of new gear
to acquire visiting Far Harbor is an
excellent way to extend your enjoyment
of Fallout 4s brand of combat and casual
roleplay but it doesn't succeed in all
of its attempts to build on the
foundation of the base game's story in
many ways far harbors seems like a trip
down memory lane you once again set out
in search of a missing child and
ultimately discover a society in the
throes of a complicated conflict the
crazed sons of Adam worship radiation
taking refuge in the dense irradiated
fog that covers the island they're at
odds with the citizens of Far Harbor the
seafaring town reduced to the only swath
of land not overrun by fog elsewhere
since who want to live in peace and
isolation watch from the sidelines
though as you soon discover a murky past
brings their motivations into question
shortly after you arrive on the island
and help defend townsfolk from invading
monsters you're whisked away to the
synth refuge in Acadia not long after
you're guided to the children of adam'
sanctuary called the nucleus unless you
deviate into side-quests right away
you'll have met most of our harbors big
players in less than an hour and these
meetings deliver a rapid-fire procession
of seemingly major events and
revelations
unfortunately this eagerness backfires
Far Harbor isn't shy about asking you to
join a murderous group of religious
extremists or attempting to make you
question your own identity while these
moments have potential they aren't given
the time and space they need to spur a
meaningful response the biggest twist of
all is so mired in logical
inconsistencies that it practically
feels like a joke after the dozens of
hours it took to form a position on the
various players and problems in the main
campaign the abrupt propositions in Far
Harbor feel cheap to say nothing of how
familiar the narratives themes are at
this stage in the game the biggest risk
Far Harbor takes is a trip into the
memory banks of a synth where you use
the settlement
tool said to recompile broken pieces of
data with a limited number of items at
your disposal you have to redirect
lasers to break down barriers and place
armaments of your own to defend the flow
of information from cannon toting
viruses all the while trying your best
not to walk into pitfalls these
sequences are visually distinct and put
your abilities as a craftsman to
practical use but they come off as a
half-baked puzzle game concocted to drum
up variety up to the last puzzle the
solutions are easy to identify and
execute the final test on the other hand
is sprawling and requires tedious
exploration made worse by the limited
amount of resources you have to build
bridges to and from the maps various
islands of data as I dug my heels in and
meticulously worked for a solution to
the final puzzle
I yearn for adventure for all the
baggage and Far Harbor is successfully
upholds fallouts tradition of combat
driven by odd requests from locals or by
your own lust for loot new weapons like
the harpoon gun empower you to take on
creatures they're fast resilient and
challenging enough to test seasoned
survivors
the only hiccup that gets in the way
comes from the fog that permeates far
harbour at least on PlayStation 4 and PC
these versions suffer from framerate
issues with the ps4 version exhibiting
choppy gameplay during exploration and
especially during combat the fog and the
light that sneaks through it creates a
great visual effect but it's a shame
that it comes at the cost of performance
for its new locations and weapons the
turbulent waters of Maine are a
satisfying complement to fallout 4 but
we're far harbour succeeds in delivering
more of the same great gameplay and
oddball characters that made the main
campaign such a joy it can't muster an
interesting story it over confidently
asserts twists and conundrums without
doing enough to earn your investment in
the outcome of your decisions if a
moving story is what you're after steer
your ship back to the shores of the
Commonwealth
you